[Musique]
bienvenue dans encore vous l'émission
qui reçoivent les personnages que vous
savez forcément déjà vu au ciné ou à la
télé mon avis tu es aujourd'hui est un
grand amateur de surprises surtout quand
c'est lui qui les fait je ressors le
personnage flippant qui apparaît quand
on ne s'y attend pas
on ne s'y attend pas bougé c'est quoi ça
et voilà
du real hello bonjour et
bienvenue et encore vous merci alors on
vous connaît bien vous êtes un habitué
des films d'horreur ah oui ces orages
apparaît souvent dans les placards
derrière les portes dans l'ombre au coin
d'une pièce mais c'est vrai que j'aime
beaucoup les armoires à pharmacie ah oui
bah ouais général on est stressé on a
besoin d'un petit cachet j'apparais est
un farceur un
peu plus vous avez raison dans une salle
de bains et pas d'issue tenir surprenant
c'était un rêve de gosse
ue et vue
à aller pardon fort fermèrent à moi je
ne parlais pas écouté notre métier est
arrivé un peu comme ça de manière assez
surprenante disons que je n'y a pas mais
pas
comment vous arrivez à concilier vie de
famille et vie de personnages qui
apparaît quand on s'y attend pas il est
où plus
un jeu
cv c'est surtout une question
d'organisation mais c'est vrai qu'en
général quand je rentre du boulot j'ai
souvent la femme ne m'attend pas
et puis j'essaie de me signaler quand
j'arrive dans un endroit je m'annonce
dans les nappes musicales
inquiétant
c'est pour ça y'a bien ronny
bonjour
m'accompagne partout il ya un rideau de
douche à tirer ou pour les exercices
aussi beaucoup ah oui donc c'est
vraiment toute une équipe auxquelles
vous faites après il est ou non c'est
plus rigolo là c'est
au bout d'un moment vous n'avez pas peur
que cet effet sont un petit peu attendu
je crois que tout est dans le dosage et
la parcimonie
le ménager
[Musique]
monsieur votre invité bador j'ai fait un
cauchemar atroce on ose 8 n arrêtait pas
d'apparaître là je m'y attendais pas moi
ça n'était qu'un rêve oui
tout va bien
[Musique]
entendez vous pouvez faire votre truc
cachez-vous yolaine parce que le uk
peut venir se plaît